hello welcome to the CEO plain brownie
mere brownie me a magazine which said
right box in which ship Wow fifty
percent sky and sand that's not much
yeah he knows his theory that's not good
I mean good for him not good for me yeah
I'm playing this line that reversed
Grand Prix and I'm not a big believer in
it to be honest so hmm this is one of
the better lines against that as far as
I know yeah I don't like it don't like
my position but maybe maybe it's not so
bad see going on each five g5 something
like that well if I get some more than a
can go G for you it's a g4 will be
tricky maybe I should have played h5
now k now g4s not so likely loan could
be six there when you'll probably move
back and don't clear what my queen is
doing there maybe I can get some clock
advantage at least yeah that makes me
nervous that G for all kinds of stuff
let's stop it why are you playing so
well that's not fair yeah it's not good
we need to get some kind of con to play
some B 5 stuff yeah this is the problem
if orbits okay he cannot so easily play
d5 and taking is also not so easy night
f5 or so it will be pretty active so
things are maybe not entirely clear yeah
so Wow I taken to go see five hmm
yeah take CA can take these six maybe
okay that is first let's first make sure
that this night is on some some tricky
spot and then we'll see night a form or
92 okay it's going there
hmm
yeah but take them yeah maybe maybe this
one it's it looks unbelievably shaky
sorry for the sound need to open up it
wasn't so loud I guess my lunch was so
spicy I need something to drink sorry
Bubba so normally I lose the game
immediately if I'm disturbed like that
probably this would happen again anyway
somes taking this see threatening
something Quincy seven maybe hmm
I could be should be seven where's he
going then d700 give seven
hmm
it's got all kinds of stuff hanging I'm
not really sure that I see something
good fam queen the d7 regev 796 King g8
don't see it efore hangs will check all
kinds of things hang
here 96 check King age 6 mmm yes no
square for the Queen wed so protects you
form
yeah it seems he doesn't doesn't find a
movie them
Quincy 7 dig and dig if I was chicken
Kim yeah I'm not sure maybe he opened up
the center to too quickly I certainly
had big trouble there that that's pretty
clear but something went went wrong here
for wide don't see a movie just letting
the clock run down 01 check ok so here I
have to do this yeah oka for Hanks and
the rookie on d1 hangs not sure what
what I should do first if I take it for
Queenie fall as g6 hanging that probably
should be avoided I cannot attack the
Queen again so that I can take you for
with check so maybe check the roof first
or check the night difficult mini I
don't know patike there 95 maybe time
morning guy anyway I have to play let's
see five there's also bishop see made ok
hmm didn't see that one coming as usual
um well Queen f7 is made so
I'm losing the rook you know I'm quite a
bit of material up so let's do this
check I thought I can take actually why
can I not take check what time I'm a
term situation is not good check check
check rotating made on c3 check all
right you cannot recapture that's good
white resign let's good Oh 23 seconds
wow what a weird game yeah the lion I am
and I sometimes play that in blitz this
reverse grand prix here but this is not
very good for black i believe and slide
and like my position at all was even
fearing something like an immediate g4
maybe it's my turn
the engine think c5 is kind of okay now
i don't like it's tough okay this
happened you played it well yeah
absolutely man I was too irritated by g4
nh5 so I went here have three now now
that should be good for white somehow
rupee aid you for be 5c 5 y and y does a
lot better this so let's see what the
point was night if form and I took here
I went here so yeah the engine disagree
with whites play quite a bit but it
wants to take on c6 now Wow okay I
cannot go 93 sg6 hangs and I'm not
saying it's not quickly I what my movers
I can also not take on defo of course m
now then it's respeta yeah there must
have been something for wide here 93 and
this is probably not so great right is
not a good shape yet seems Queenie sex
this is what he played they took this
Bishop g6 yeah wide widths according to
the engine I'm a rook up at the moment
but ok he's got quite some ponds and
well the position okay I went here
chattox this is losing this is the
losing move it seems that this is
winning four wide don't quite get it at
the moment so let's say i'll take the
rook he cheeks and cheeks check how is
he winning ah ok ok ok ok ah white wins
check
check check check so this was check
there's only this she's handing me the
game check and check I hope I didn't
blunder a bishop before was made yeah
okay I had no time I was glad that has
spotted Quincy three made Queen a
coincidence is a cute made check I had
to play mate instant moose check and you
he resigned wow that was tough oh thanks
for watching